markus söder vor ort die meisten
ministerpräsidenten hatten sich
zugeschaut markus söder ist in berlin
und wir hatten nach dem statement die
möglichkeit mit ihm zu sprechen und auch
da waren natürlich das thema schulen und
wie es dort jetzt weitergeht wichtig die
im abitur stecken können sich darauf
verlassen es würde ein abitur geben es
wird nicht irgendein notabitur geben
es wird nicht irgendein durchschnitts
abi geben für alle beteiligten sondern
er soll nach besten wissen und gewissen
eine gute abiturprüfung werden
das sind dürfen die als erste anfangen
in allen anderen fällen muss muss man
sehr genau überlegen
also wir müssen über die kultusminister
noch mal überlegen wie sieht es generell
in der schule aus welche unterricht muss
in anderen klassen stattfinden
ob da nur kernfächer beispielsweise sind
wie man das zeitversetzt organisieren
kann
wie die schülerbeförderung organisiert
werden kann auch mit entsprechenden
schutz in den bussen beispielsweise wo
auch ein mast angebot sinnvoll wäre und
was mir noch persönlich wichtig ist dass
man die versetzung frage klärt also
manche schüler haben einfach zu wenig
zeit gehabt um sich vielleicht noch mal
gut in szene zu setzen in der schule die
dann vielleicht im schulalter geschafft
hätten da müssen wir noch was überlegen
keiner sollte mein name nach sitzen
bleiben nur weil wegen corona die
schulzeit verkürzt würde also beim thema
schulen gibt es noch sehr sehr viele
offene fragen die geklärt werden müssen
dasselbe gilt auch für die sommerferien
und den gebuchten sommerurlaub keiner
stattfinden oder nicht auch darüber
haben wir markus söder befragt meine
einschätzung ist wenn man das
infektionsgeschehen anderen ländern
anschaue dann ist der urlaub wohl es ihr
und besser dieses jahr in deutschland zu
machen wo es wundervolle ziele gibt man
hat ja ohnehin erlebt dass viele
menschen die oft gesagt habe ist
deutschland zu langweilig oder
uninteressant und sie können das hier
gerade mal aushalten zu leben
alle wollten nach hause und man sieht
doch mal bei aller schwäche die unser
land auch hat uns geht es da schon in
der relation zu anderen ganz gut und wir
ein tolles gesundheitssystem und
deswegen glaube ich auch einmal urlaub
in deutschland ist für viele schön ich
kann bayern beispielsweise 0 für ihren
sommerurlaub also nur in bayern das sagt
markus söder zumindest in deutschland
sollte man jetzt planen sein sommer zu
verbringen weiterreisen sieht er eher
nicht